but I really wanted to do this topic. I changed the title because I think
this conference and all the conferences I've been to in the last, you know, three, six months,
yes, there are toxicities. We are messing people's immune systems up, right? Amazing responses,
bispecifics, CAR Ts, but thinking about all the rheumatological things we learned in the past,
sometimes these T cells are going to do things that we don't know about. And it's really important
to figure that out and then learn how to actually treat those patients and then eventually prevent
it so that we can use these amazing therapies for our patients. So again, I still start with
this is the reason I didn't quit during COVID and I didn't go to pharma because my patients
did so well on a therapy that I thought these patients were going to die. I didn't know that
they were going to actually live for years, five years for some patients. They actually respond
to treatments after CAR-T therapy, even when they're relapsing. The majority of my patients,
when they relapse from CAR-T, even if they don't make it to five years, I have options for other
lines of therapy. We heard a little bit about lymphoma where after bispecifics, it's harder
to treat those patients, especially if they're on continuous dosing. So I wanted to say,
I still think CAR-T is really, really important. And I still offer it to most of my patients in
second line. Again, I get I'm in a bubble and I have access to all these things, but most of my
patients, even standard dress, because of those outcomes, we'll go to second line CAR-T. And I
think that's the big message here, that everything is an evolution, right? So yes, the delayed
neurotoxicity that we saw with CARTATUDE1, 6%. And again, there's been a lot of work done at Mount
Sinai and lots of other places that have really looked at this. I will say in my standard of care
practice, I actually have done a lot of work on CARTATUDE1. I've done a lot of work on CARTATUDE2.
Zero patients out of 190 we've treated now that have gotten Guillain-Barre or Parkinson's.
Again, I'm going to talk about why I think that is, but really we've learned this and this really
changes that outcome. And again, even in CARTATUDE4, it was a 0.51 patient that had Parkinson's,
right? So really important to know these things and figure out how to fix it and prevent it and
treat it if it does happen. But again, it changes from two, three years ago to what it is today.
And same thing with IEC colitis. Some of our patients have had some serious IEC colitis,
and that's what I'm going to share in a little bit.
So again, I'm not going to read most of my slides. It's there for you to look at later,
but really there are some mechanisms as why we think maybe the neurotoxicity happens. I do think
the neurotox versus the IEC colitis are probably a little different. There are some patients that
can get both, but again, important. CLOUDIN9, the reason I brought this up, all of these things are
multifactorial. I will say that yes, there is a target called CLOUDIN9 that is something that
all of us have on neural tissues normally expressed in studies. We don't know that the
actually plays a role in any of the neurotoxicity that happens in either the MNTs or the
Parkinsonianism type. But in the lab, we can see that if there's increased CLOUDIN9, that there
are certain CAR-Ts that attach to that and others don't. So again, it's a hypothesis. It does not
mean it's the main cause, but really important to know because again, if it was not increased
expression, then why are these patients getting it? Not everybody. And I think again, some of it
has to do with the expansion of the CAR-Ts. We've talked about ALC. I'm going to come to that in a
second.
Versus is there also a role for a particular antigen? We don't know. And so in terms of
diagnosis and clinical features, I'm not going to go into it. But again, MNTs versus Parkinsonianism,
they are a little bit different. Most of these patients, usually a month after is where we start
seeing a day 28, 20, 30 or later, and usually in the first three to six months. So to most of my
patients, I tell them if three to six months, you're doing great. I'm actually not worried
too much about you. I have a few patients that even a year or two years later, they might have
personality changes and we do something to figure that out. But again, the majority of
patients, once they're out three to six months, things look really exciting and then I don't see
them, but every three months. And so the biggest thing I will say is that prevention strategies,
I think the effect of bridging. Again, CARTITUDE 1 versus CARTITUDE 4, we saw that patients who got
better bridging had a much lower risk of all of these toxicities, especially Parkinsonianism.
Cranial nerve palsies, maybe not. Again, I haven't seen as many in our earlier line patients now,
which I don't know exactly why. But in the late line patients,
even with great bridging, we would see some of these cranial nerve palsies. So we would just
pick up on them really fast, treat them, and most of those patients turned around within a week or
two. The Parkinson's, again, much lower risk when you actually improve bridging. So the question is,
is it expansion or are there other things? Now, of course, the ALC, we came up with this argument
yesterday too, that there are some centers that will treat an ALC of three to five with steroids,
other centers like Mayo that will actually maybe even give Cytoxan. And our center doesn't give
anything unless they have something to do with it. But there are centers that will actually maybe even
give Cytoxan. And our center doesn't give anything unless they have something to do with it.
And our center doesn't give anything unless they have something to do with it.
And so again, I think everything's evolving so much that some of these differences we're seeing
could just be that we're getting better at treating our patients, and especially earlier
line. Okay. And then the only other thing I wanted to bring up for standard of care is, remember,
in trials, patients cannot, they have washout windows, we have to wait. We only give certain
kinds of bridging sometimes. Where in the real world, I am free to do so many other things. So
I will say it is harder for me to treat a patient on a clinical trial, even though those patients are
eligible for trials, than treating a patient for standard of care CAR-T that isn't eligible for a
trial. So the logistics make a huge difference in what I can and can't do. So with IUC colitis,
most of this data is from Mark Hamilton and Lekha Milkaneni from our consortium, as well as MD
Anderson data that I'm showing you here. And again, this does seem to be, these papers have
been submitted, so I don't have pictures. I have some of the data from their posters from ASTCT.
But really, it does seem to be that the patients who get this, it seems to be a lymphoproliferative
disorder and not necessarily gynecological. And so I think it's really important that we
make sure that we're not just a immune-mediated enterocolitis. There are certain cell types that
we're seeing. We do see clonal CAR-T expansion, but they are not just TET2 or some of the things
that Gurbaksh talked about earlier. There's other clones that we're seeing that we don't know exactly
what to make of. What's interesting, this is not colitis, this is enterocolitis. So what makes it
easier to diagnose now is that for most of our patients, the second they have major symptoms, we
actually do an EGD. So I don't have to worry about cleaning out their colons, et cetera, and I can get
it done really quickly.
The incidence, 5.1% for our patients when we had up to 158 patients. Thankfully, getting up to 190
or so now, we haven't had another case. So we'll see. But again, really important to monitor for
this. And so what we see here, I'm going to talk about the key diagnostic thresholds. What we
figured out from the nine patients that we had, these were patients that at day 28, 30, when we
checked their CAR-T expansion, because we can follow that at MD Anderson, if they were 100
cells per microliter at day 28 or 30, they had a higher risk. Not everybody gets it, but they had a
much higher risk than any of the patients that had less. Our T's go up, but they come down. But if
they stay high, then we worry. And then we have a test with that pathology. When we do that EGD, we
can actually look for camelid. And we decided that if it was 20% or more, we'd go ahead and call it
IEC colitis and treat it. And then even if you have low inflammatory markers, you don't see anything
on imaging, this still could be IEC colitis. And again, intervening early is what helps. So I'm
going to quickly just say for our patients, this is our pathway we have right now. It's evolving. If we
treat a patient with IEC colitis, they can have infections at the same time. You treat the
infection two, three days later, they're not getting better. We get the EGD. We see this
diagnostic on path. This is the pathway for treatment. If their PS is zero to two, they don't
have serious infections issues, we try to kill the T cells. So that's usually with Cytoxan-based
therapy followed by rexalitinib and VEDO. So when these patients have leaders of diarrhea, things
like rexalitinib, they can't actually absorb it. We actually see the pills come out. So we use it
as maintenance after, but really
the T cells, most of our patients resolved within one to two weeks. And then we were able to do some
type of maintenance. With patients who are a little bit more frail, we've actually gotten
some responses with cyclosporine or tacrolimus. It's a little bit harder. We do IV first again,
because they can't absorb, but eventually we go to a maintenance there. And so with that,
I'm just going to come back here again. You'll have all the slides and some of the
other data that's in there, but really I think this is one of the best therapies we've seen,
especially the one in Dunn. Our patients feel great. I have patients that go back to work.
It's really big.
So I think the goal is not to fear these toxicities. It's really to recognize them,
act swiftly and figure out how we can prevent them in the future.